all right welcome back we are talking
fashion for everyone all ages sizes
abilities backgrounds you name it I'm
joined by Las Vegas native Suzanne
Finnick of by vinnick to tell us more
about this company that you've launched
but first Suzanne welcome thanks for
being here now you are a native lva you
said Cimarron High School but your your
true love is Opera that's how you really
got your start in this entertainment
type world yeah I actually started
performing when I was eight years old
here on the Las Vegas Strip oh my god um
and performed for like any cultural
event that came through or like high
rollers events like I used to sing at
the Westward Ho wow so and now your
talents have taken you pretty much
everywhere and and now you've kind of
launched this line which is really
wonderful because looking at your
website seeing the designs not only is
it affordable you know the price points
are affordable for women but it's size
inclusive why is that so important
Suzanne well there's just so few options
for Divas around the world to wear
clothes that are really beautifully made
that are ethically made everything that
we do is made in Los Angeles everybody
earns a fair wage for it so it's not
like other brands where it's like you
know there might be people being
exploited children making your clothes
so we just we have a really good handle
on what's Happening and where it's made
and we really we want to be the fashion
line for everybody who's been left out
of the conversation and it is I mean
it's high fashion it's beautiful and
talk about what you have here this is
fun this is a purse yes it's one of um
it's one of our little bags that we have
we also have accessories on the website
but all of the apparel again is made in
La it's all designed by me we have all
these limited edition drops that we you
do so you can be you can rest assured
that not not a bunch of people are going
to have your outfit and maybe you'll be
the only one who does oh I love it now
some of the fabric I mean this is just
gorgeous I'm loving the the gold and the
black hair jacket just stunning thank
you and nice I mean really like Quality
quality fabric here
um this has been a popular line Jennifer
Coolidge has already worn her designs in
white loaded yes that is wonderful and
that's wild um RuPaul Drag Race one of
the guest judges yes I mean so Suzanne
here you are launching this incredible
line for all women and now already
you're making a big splash yeah I can't
believe in three and a half years that
I've been able to accomplish what I have
and you know just bring fashion to the
masses and kudos to you and it is it
truly is beautiful absolutely beautiful
really quick before I send it over to
John how can people find your your line
where is it available it's available on
my website which is bybinic.com okay so
you can go there you can shop till
you're till your heart drops and you can
have a great time it could be a good
Valentine's Day gift gentlemen yes
print out a picture and be like this is
what I got you see that that would be a
good man Suzanne thank you so much for
being on the show this morning a Las
Vegas native with so much going on we're
we're going to be following you all
right John over to you